[Música]
y continuamos en economía con Daniela
hablando con nuestro estudio para hablar
de Europa porque ahí acuerdan Dani una
ley que impide importar productos
vinculados a la deforestación muy buen
día Hola Buenos días Raúl pues mire la
historia solamente falta que los países
miembros y el parlamento europeo
aprueben formalmente una legislación
para que se comiencen a aplicar fuertes
multas a aquellas empresas que vendan
productos como café carne de res o soya
sin que demuestren que en la cadena de
suministro no hubo deforestación entre
los países que se verían afectados están
Brasil Indonesia y Colombia que es desde
donde más denuncias hay de este tipo de
actividad ilegal hay un caso muy
renombrado que probablemente recordará
que es el del gigante francés de
supermercados casino Y es que un
tribunal en París desde mediados de este
año está examinando las denuncias de
indígenas que lo acusan de comercializar
carne producida en fincas que causan
deforestación en Suramérica en especial
en la amazonía que comparten Colombia y
Brasil y en qué consiste toda esta
normativa Dani Bueno entonces los
comercializadores de alimentos tendrán
que representar que presentar mejor y de
productos de otros productos una
declaración que demuestre que sus
cadenas de suministro no están
contribuyendo a la destrucción de los
bosques si se comprueba lo contrario o
simplemente no presentan esta
declaración podrían enfrentar muertes
fuertes multas que van hasta el 4% de su
facturación o también se aplicará a
otros productos que ya mencionamos al
aceite de Palma la madera el cacao el
caucho y derivados como el cuero el
chocolate y los muebles
y la zona Euro buscará también
reorientar las ayudas energéticas
seguimos en Europa seguimos en Europa
porque a raíz de la guerra en Ucrania
los precios del gas y la electricidad se
dispararon a niveles inimaginables y la
respuesta comunitaria fue entregar ayuda
universales por ejemplo reducción de
impuestos que benefician a todo el
conjunto de la población esto ha sido
muy criticado por el Banco Central
europeo que dice que eso ayuda a crear
presiones inflacionarias es decir que
los precios suban más los ministros de
finanzas de la eurozona es decir los 19
países que comparten el euro como moneda
acordaron que desde 2023 van a poner el
foco de esas ayudas únicamente sobre las
partes más afectadas por la inflación
como lo son los hogares vulnerables y
las empresas y no sobre toda la
población la propuesta concretamente
consiste en seguir subsidiando parte de
las facturas de energía y gas pero dejar
que otra parte se pague a precio de
mercado porque así se incentiva una
reducción en la demanda Y es que también
hay quienes dicen que subvencionar estos
servicios hacen que la gente Simplemente
no ahorre porque se lo regalan y nos
venimos a nuestra región precisamente
aquí donde emitimos en France 24 en
español Colombia porque no sé si usted
Daniela ha ido a hacer mercado pues
últimamente no sí yo siempre soy
haciendo mercado y todo el tiempo me
asombro de los precios bueno Daniela y
vamos a hablar de eso luego pero
seguimos digamos en Francia qué está
pasando también en ese país hay un
problema con los vinos no hay un
problema con los vinos porque la región
francesa de burdeos mundialmente famosa
por la producción de esta bebida está en
crisis los viticultores que son Quienes
se encargan de la fermentación de la uva
piden una compensación para mantener
esta producción milenaria mientras se
adaptan a nuevos retos como la inflación
o el cambio climático para los próximos
días inclusive Se esperan huelgas a
nivel nacional veámoslo en el siguiente
informe
en solo unas semanas el paisaje de esta
viñedo podría cambiar radicalmente en la
renombrada región vinícola de burdeus
este viticultor es tan solo uno de los
muchos que abogan por cambiar sus
queridas cosechas
decir que tenemos que acabar con este
viñedo que hemos construido Durante los
últimos 20 años es desgarrador por
supuesto pero dependemos de un mercado
de reglas y estándares que nos han
llevado a esta situación tenemos dos
opciones reaccionar o enfrentarnos algo
muy grave para los sindicatos Esta es la
única forma de avanzar hacia un tipo de
agricultura diferente y abordar la
crisis de sobreproducción que amenaza el
primer viñedo que obtuvo el famoso sello
de denominación de origen en Francia ya
no es el trabajo del que paga sino el
mercado el que manda la situación se ha
deteriorado Durante los últimos años en
2005 un barril de vino tinto de 900
litros se vendía por unos mil euros hoy
su precio oscila 600 cuando se
necesitaría el doble de esa cantidad
para cubrir los costos actuales hay
varios factores involucrados en la
crisis mientras que las cosechas están
en declive debido al cambio climático
Los costos de producción están
aumentando a medida que se dispara la
inflación pero también hay una caída en
las ventas de vino en Francia y en el
extranjero
normalmente este vino estaba antes del
periodo donde teníamos el mercado chino
hoy debería estar en las mesas de los
chinos
en general los productores ya no pueden
vender sus cultivos para mantenerse a
flote y están pidiendo al gobierno una
compensación que podría ascender a los
10.000 euros por hectárea lo que
reduciría significativamente el tamaño
de los viñedos
bueno Daniela cifra del día el 11,7%
de 10 Corporation el lunes tras revisar
a la baja sus proyecciones de 2023 y
cambiar de presidente ejecutivo esta
empresa de la que probablemente no le
suena el nombre es la dueña de marcas
como North Face
o Timberland y cree que debido a la
desaceleración económica la demanda de
sus productos no va a ser como esperada
bueno Y además porque son costosos no
porque son muy costosos entonces están
más costoso la gente no compra y le
quedó debiendo y me queda siguiendo
Colombia Exacto porque qué va a pasar
con la inflación aquí en este país que
cada día sube y sube Dani Muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información Más adelante hablamos de
Colombia en la próxima crónica en la
próxima Crónica y nosotros hablamos de
deportes con